the Joe Rogan experience like Twitter is
great for just getting out information
letting people know about something you
know you find something but I use it
mostly I find cool stories like if I
read some cool article that I was
reading some article about China has
made pig monkey hybrids China yeah and
they've successfully made these Pig
monkey hybrids and you know they didn't
show they showed a picture of a pig
fetus I'm pretty sure it's just a
regular pig fetus but they weren't they
didn't stay alive very long the ideas
they want to get to a point was it Pig
human or Pig monkey I think it was pig
monkey Pig my new tweeted was Pig heard
about yeah how's Joan says they're doing
picking with you I bet he's right
I guarantee he's right I do they do pig
monkey and then just like a little baby
boy is born but I think what they're
trying to do is develop pigs their their
hearts and a lot of their organs are
very similar to ours mm-hmm and their
digestive tract is very similar to ours
like there's certain tests they do on
how things are digested and they do them
through Pig stomachs people they do a
lot of transplants with pigs now - yes
so I think that's the ideas eventually
get to a point where you can get
harvestable organs from pigs mm-hmm you
know so they'd have some sort of a pig
human hybrid but you know someone's
gonna [ __ ] one someone's gonna bring it
home and I mean get some pig lady
walking for you it's kind of a human
vagina
yeah always wait where does that saying
come from like a drum like a drums pull
tight okay sorry sometimes I'm the
dumbest person in the world I'm like
yeah I'm looking I was like put dress up
like a pretty big hole in the back don't
you're a hundred percent right tight
like a drum is a dumb way to describe a
vagina for sure yeah yeah I don't think
it but I guess it was there's like a
weird covering yeah over a vagina
like a like a Mason's fist like a
sliggoo yeah like a stonemason someone's
carries bricks every day and as fast
strong hands tight like a butthole like
a strong bubble some squats a lot
[Applause]